همم اهلا بكم مشاهدي- اا الجزيره على
انستغرام ثمانيه ايام فقط تفصلنا عن اكبر
حدث رياضيا في العالم ثمانيه ايام تفصلنا
عن اول استضافه لدوله عربيه ومسلمه لكاس
العالم منذ انطلاقه عام 1930 قد يختزل
البعض هذا الحدث الهام في التنافس الرياضي
بين الدول غير ان هناك ميدان اخر يستعر
فيه التنافس ايضا وهو ميدان الثقافه والفن
حيث تنبري كل دوله مستضيفه لهذه البطوله
في محاوله الجده وذوبه لاظهار هويتها
وثقافتها وحضارتها امام مليارات البشر عبر
قارات العالم في فرصه استثنائيه نادره
وبما ان الفن هو مراته المجتمع فقد كان
لاغاني كاس العالم دائما دور محوري في
التعبير عن تراثي وثقافه الدول المستضيفه
لهذه البطوله
وهو ما ظهر جليا في النسخ الماضيه من كاس
العالم اليوم ضيفتنا هي الفنانه والمطربه
القطريه عائشه والتي شاركت في اول اغنيه
ضمن الالبوم الرسمي لكاس العالم قطر 2022
وهي حتى الان القطريه الوحيده التي مثلت
قطر في اغاني كاس العالم حتى هذه اللحظه
وسيدور النقاشنا معها حول تجربتها
الغنائيه
وبدايتها كذلك وقصه اغنيه كاس العالم التي
شاركت فيها ورايها في اغاني كؤوس العالم
السابقه ورايها كذلك عن الفن والغناء
والطرب في قطر وكذلك فعاليه ومشاركه
المراه القطريه في المجال العام وغيرها
همم من المواضيع التي سنناقشها مع ضيفتنا
اليوم اهلا بك عائشه
اهلا ام محمد
خلال هذا البث المباشر والذي سنقوم بنقلها
بنقل هذه الاسئله لها خلال هذه الحلقه
طيب
انا خلصت اللغه العربيه عائشه هنبدا بقى
نتكلم بقى
بدايه
اغنيه هيا هيا وهي تقريبا هي اول اغنيه
وكان الناس
سواقين لان يروا كيف ستعبر قطر عن نفسها
همم بشكل كبير من خلال همم
اغاني كاس العالم
تجربتك في اول اغنيه همم
تقييمك لهذه التجربه بشكل كبير
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه لي انا كانت تجربه وايد حلوه
وايد كان في حماس
اكشن
اعتبر نفسي يعني محظوظه اني اول اغنيه لهي
اغنيه كاس العالم
صراحه كانت على مستوى انا اعتبرها مستوى
عالي وحتى من ردود افعال الناس انه
مستواها تشوف لنا مستوى الدوليه يعني
صراحه
بالنسبه لك همم تجربه شخصيه كانت همم وايد
حلوه ومن اهم تجارب يعني في الحياه
همم طيب همم
الردود الفعل من داخل قطر ومن خارج قطر
على الاغنيه ومشاركتك انت كفتات قطريه في
هذه الاغنيه كانت ايه
الحمد لله بشكل عام
ردود الفعل كانت ايجابيه الحمد لله يعني
الناس اعجبتهم الاغنيه
في ناس يعني كان عندهم انتقادات بس بشكل
عام يعني الناس اعجبتهم وكان فيها يعني
الروح الرياضيه روح
يعني الفيفارات كاس العالم
والاغنيه سهله حفظ
انها كانت اغنيه مناسبه حق كاس العالم
والناس عليها الحمد لله طيب انت قلت لنا
ان في همم انتقادات
كانت ايه هي الانتقادات او ابرز
الانتقادات اللي وصلتك عن الاغنيه
[موسيقى]
شويه
اكثر انا اشوف من وجهه نظري هاي وجهه نظري
انا يعني
اي حد ثاني اشوف ان موجود هاي لان اذا شفت
اغنيتها يعني فيها دفوف اذا شفت
الثياب وتشوف يعني في من الثقافه اللي
فيها موجوده بس مسوينها بطريقه
همم
في فوائد كبيره
حدث عالمي فلازم يكون كان مترجم بالعربي
[موسيقى]
هو هو اه يعني انا انا بصراحه قرات كتير
في ردود الفعل وكان فيه
يعني انتقادات
وجهت لفكره اللغه الانجليزيه تحديدا اللي
ضغط على الالبوم الغنائي مش ليس فقط
الاغنيه الاولى ولكن الاغنيه الاولى
والثانيه والثالثه
ان راي بعض الناس همم
يعني ليه اللغه العربيه
اللغه الرسميه لقطر ولل الدول العربيه
كلها ليست حاضره بشكل كبير جدا همم اضافه
لان يعني زي ما انت بتقولي كده الناس
شايفه ان همم ما فيش تمثيل واضح بشكل كبير
اللهم الا في الاغنيه الاولانيه الانت
ظهرت فيها بالذي وكان ظاهره الدفوف همم
جنبك بشكل او باخر والزي القطري كان حاضر
يعني لكن ما سوى ذلك حتى هذه اللحظه لم
يظهر
بصراحه انا اشوف الظهر بس
بطرق مختلفه يعني مثلا في اغنيه
يعني اللي ظهر شويه تردشن الاكثر بس مثلا
اذا شفت ارحبوا يعني يبين الوجه الجديد
المودرن اللي اللي صارت صارت قطر الحين
مثلا الملاعب هاي يعني
نصور كلها في قطر
كلهم يعني قطر والاستوديو
مهما كان صح لنا مثلا الاغنيه الثانيه
طيب بما انك انت القطريه الوحيده حتى هذه
اللحظه او الفنانه القطريه الوحيده حتى
هذه اللحظه اللي ظهرت في الاغاني الرسميه
لكاس العالم في اغنيه اللي هي همم عملتها
اريده وكان كل المشاركين فيها يا شباب عرب
من الدول العربيه لكن في الاغاني الرسميه
اللي في فيفا حتى الان انت القطريه
الوحيده
ليه ما شفناش مثلا القطريين فبقيه الاغاني
وهل بتحسي ان ان ده مسؤوليه كبيره ان
الاغنيه الوحيده اللي ظهرت هي اللي انت
شاركت فيها بس ال- القطريه يعني
ايه اكيد مسؤوليه كبيره
بس الحمد لله يعني انا اتقبل هالمسؤوليه
وان شاء الله اكون يعني
مسويتها عدل بس
ما ما احس انه هاي صح
الاوفيشن هاي بس بس انا احس انه حتى اغنيه
اريد اللي طلعت بالعربي
زين وعندها يمكن 20 من اخر مره شفت همم 20
مليون
المغنيين اللي فيها يعني ناصر القويسمه
همم
[موسيقى]
سعودي سعودي
بقى شويه صعب احس انه بالعكس البطاقه
قاعده تحاول قدر الامكان انها تلبي
طلباتهم
ويعني دليل ان تشوف مثلا روسيا يوم طلعوا
اغاني ما في اغنيه روسيه ما عندي ولا بلد
يعني على على حسب علمي يعني ما اعتقد انه
في اغنيه روسيه لكاس العالم ولا في اغنيه
برازيليه لكاس العالم
اغنيه كاس العالم الرسميه في يوم الافتتاح
ربما كلها
تنجح باللغه العربيه فقط الا انت شايفه ان
جزء من نجاح اي اغنيه بتتغنى للعالم كله
انها تكون في مساحه فيها باللغه العالميه
ربما اللي هي اللغه الانجليزيه
وان ده
بيسهل فكره اا توصيل الرساله وتوصيل
الثقافه للدوله المستضيفه بشكل سلس وسهل
للجمهور لمليارات البشر اللي بتابعه
حوالين كاس العالم
انه افضل
اذا سوينا بس اغنيه بالعربي يعني
همم حدث عالمي فا صعب نجي ونغيره بعد
سنوات
بس اغاني مثلا بالعربي
فعلها اكثر من اغنيه هاي افضل شيء عشان
الكل يكون يعني الكل عنده اغنيه يحس انها
هي همم تعبر عنها ولا هو يعني كناكت معها
فهمم
[موسيقى]
هل هنشوف عائشه في افتتاح كاس العالم ضمن
اغنيه الافتتاح ولا ولا لا
للاسف ما اقدر اقول بس
ان شاء الله يعني ههه
من اغاني كاس العالم قبل كده الكاس العالم
يعني يعني كان في اغاني كثير جدا تغني فيك
رؤوس العالم اللي فاتت وفي اغاني
نجحتش النجاح المبهر اللي كان منتظر لكن
في اغاني حتى هذه اللحظه الناس يرددوها
بيغنوها يعني على سبيل المثال اغنيه كاس
العالم 2010 جنوب افريقيا
[موسيقى]
بهذا الشكل اغنيه برده بتاعه كاس العالم
في فرنسا اغنيه
اللي لو
جديد في اغنيه كاس العالم الرسميه في يوم
الافتتاح ستؤدي الى ان تنجح هذه الاغنيه
بشكل كبير
[موسيقى]
كاس العالم انه يكون لحنها سهل حفظ
وانا تشوفنا رضوان ما شاء الله عليه هو
ترى اللي لحاله كتب كل الاغاني كاس العالم
بتشوف ان هي
ايه كل شيء كل شيء هو اللي
هو يعني ما شاء الله عليه يعرف يكتب اغاني
سهله حفظ
وفيها تكرار انا اشوف اهم شيء في اغنيه
كاس العالم
عشان الكل يحفظها والكل يقدر يغنيها
وبس والله تكون يعني تكون حلوه وفيها يعني
انا
اكثر اغنيه من اغاني كاس العالم اللي فاتت
ان هي تتكرر مره ثانيه
في كاس العالم 2020 في قطر
والله جوابي ما بيكون يعني
[موسيقى]
انا حتى بالنسبه 2010 كان من افضل من افضل
المونديال بس هيك تجربه شخصيه
هاي كانت اول مره
اتابع المباريات من البدايه مع اهلي وحتى
طلعت النهائي مع اهلي وكل ما تجمعنا فتمت
معي يعني
ذكرني في ايام كاس العالم
والحماس اللي اللي حتى لو مثلا ما كنت
اعرف وايد عن كره القدم
[موسيقى]
طيب هل هل وجود مطربين عالميين في اغاني
كاس العالم هو هيكون هو السر الرئيسي في
نجاح وانتشار الاغنيه دي ولا ممكن ما
يكونش في نجوم كبار ومعروفين بس الاغنيه
رغم ذلك تنجح بالتون بتاعها بالعناصر
الاخرى اللي ممكن تكون موجوده فيها و
بمطربين محليين ربما يعني
[موسيقى]
اغنيه
الناس ما كانت تعرفني بس مع ذلك يعني
عجبتهم الاغنيه
بس يمكن يعني ممكن بس اكيد مثلا همم
فاذا طلعت اغنيه الناس كلها على طول بتروح
تسمعها فاكيد يعني
كده نتوقع اني شفتك شاكيرا في افتتاح كاس
العالم
[ضحك]
انتقل لمحور ثاني خاص
بالموسيقى والطرف في قطر همم تحديدا
الليبر رايك حتى هذه اللحظه حضور
الاغنيه القطريه او الفنانين والمطربين
القطريين في الساحه العربيه همم يعني حتى
هذه اللحظه ربما يكون ضعيف مقارنه بدول
خليجيه اخرى همم او مقارنه حتى ب همم
مطربين موجودين في في دول عربيه اخرى هل
ده رغم ان ان قطر مثلا متفوقه في بعض
المناحي الاخرى مثل الاعلام الرياضي ربما
قطر متفرقه ولا حسبت رياضه في المساحه
هديه في ربما في الاعلام الاخباري طبعا
لان انا باكلمك من ال- اا من الجزيره همم
لكن
ليه حتى هذه اللحظه الاغنيه القطريه مش مش
واضحه على الساحه الفنيه في العالم العربي
وكذلك المطربين القطريه
[موسيقى]
يعني تعرف
المطرب المغني صار لكبيسي يعني
قصدي قصدي
[موسيقى]
اكيد اكيد ممكن ممكن تدينا اشارات او او
يعني او ايه ايه شكل هذا التطور اللي بيتم
وبيتم في اي اتجاه تحديدا
[موسيقى]
يعني وقعوني
كاس العرب
[موسيقى]
اكترين وما شاء الله عليهم يعني كانت
اتمنى انه يوم من الايام اه ما بس يقررون
انهم يطلعون لانه في تالنت باسم مخبي هاي
هاي هو يطلعون يوم من الايام ان شاء الله
اول مره
وتكون مطرب وتبدا شيء جديد يعني
همم
فان شاء الله عاد يوم من الايام
اللي مش عارف مش راضيين يقرروا دول
الاولاد ولا بنات ولا الاثنين تمام
انت اتكلمت على تطور في سياق ان ان دلوقتي
في محاوله لاستقطاب المطربين الشباب
القطريين ومحاوله من من شركات الانتاج
ودفعهم للواجهه وانتاج اغاني لهم بشكل او
باخر طيب
ازاي برده اضافتا لهذا العنصر ازاي يمكن
الاغنيه في قطر ان هي تكون اكثر حضوره
واوسع انتشارا
خلال الفتره الجايه يعني
هل في عناصر اخرى هل فيه اا عوامل ثانيه
ممكن ان هي تدفع في هذا الاتجاه
والله ما تشوف لنا الحين فرصتنا
يعني شعر مع العالم لان الكل قاعدين الكل
عيون عليه علينا علينا
[موسيقى]
اللي عنده اغنيه حاطه على الانستغرام
واللي يبي يسوي يشتغل مع فنانين عالمين
يعني الحين صارت اسهل
خاصه
بالنسبه اللي انا اشوف
مع كاس العالم صار عندهم يعني علاقات
عالميين مطربين عالميين هاي الي صار صار
عندنا
يعني
في حد من الجمهور اسمه احمد اشرف بيسال
بيقول هل في اغاني ثانيه في البوم كاس
العالم
والله
غير الاغاني اللي اسمها ما اقدر اقوله
غنائي لان كل كل الكؤوس
هل في اغاني ثانيه ضمن البوم غير اغاني
لاغنيه الافتتاح واغنيه
الختام الختام كاس العالم هل في اغاني
ثانيه ضمن الالبوم سيتم انتاجها او هتظهر
قبل افتتاح كاس العالم لربما يعني
اذا تبون نسال على الاستديو
هيبقوا معنا همم
قريب جدا ان شاء الله طيب
انت في سياق اجابتك عن عن سؤال ايه اللي
المفروض يتعمل في ال- في الاغنيه القطريه
قلت ان في ناس قال ربما حتى هذه اللحظه
مترددين همم ان هم يشاركوا وهمم ربما في
ناس هنا بيتكلموا عن مشاركه المراه بشكل
عام في
المجال العام في قطر في شتى النواحي في
المجال الفني او في المجال الغنائي او في
مجال السينما او في همم في مجال السياسي
او في غيرها من الامور انت كشخص معروف
الان وهو جزء من هذا المجال العام كيف
تقيمين او كيف تقيم عائشه الفتاه القطريه
مشاركه المراه القطريه في المجال العام في
قطر
كيف اقيم
ما ادري اذا فهمت السؤال عدل بس قصدك هل
هو سهل يعني بدنا نطلع
لها حضور فعلا في المجال العام
واضحه وموجوده ولا لا
يشتغلون بس وراء الكواليس هم اللي شايلين
ال همم هم اللي شايلين همم عندك مثلا قبل
فتره كان عندنا لان عم تخرج من الجامعه
الاردنيه قطر وكان عندنا همم اذن همم
جابوا كل اللي تخرجه من الجامعه اللي هم
يشتغلون في كاس العالم يعني اشتغلوا مع
كاس العالم الحين همم منهم همم
بثينه بثينه المفتاح هي اللي هي اللي سوت
كوستر كاس العالم فاطمه
[موسيقى]
فاطمه الجيبه فاطمه الجيده بعدها كم
مسؤولات مسؤوله عن الانترتينمنت في
الكورنيش فيعني في في وايد ناس
حتى لو ماء ما يبينون في الواجهه اهما
موجودين واهم مسؤولين عن وادي الشمس في
كاس العالم
في
المجال العام بشكل عام
انا في وجهه نظري بالعكس في سبورت اكثر من
كل شيء فيه سبورت
لمحور الشخصي لان فيه
[موسيقى]
يعني في ناس كثير حابه تتعرف اكثر على على
عائشه
لاول مره في اول كليب لها
كلمينا عن البدايه كيف بداتي في الغناء
لحد لما وصلتي لان انت تكوني ممثله قطر
كفتاه قطريه في اول اغنيه من البوم كاس
العالم 2020
امم في البدايه بدايه احط فيديوهاتك في
انستغرام
من اول حفلات كانت
افتتاح همم
سنه 2019
اربع دقات 2018
يعني اربع سنين
[موسيقى]
المشاركه بتاعتك ديت في في اول البوم او
اول اغنيه في البوم كاس العالم دي
سيتبعها حضور بقى لعائشه هل هنشوف قلبهم
غنائي لعائشه قريب مثلا ولا هتستمر في انك
انت تنزلي اغنيه كده كل كل فتره زي ما كنت
بتعملي قبل كده
ان شاء الله والله الخطه اني
ابي انزل البوم ان شاء الله هاي الخطه بعد
كاس العالم لان الحين الكل مشغول
في العالم ان شاء الله طيب
ناخذ تسريب من الالبوم ده ممكن تغني شيء
من الالبوم الجديد
شوي شوي بس طيب
اوكي
ما بقول اسم الاغنيه بس
بغني شوي منها
اوكي
ماشي
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
كده الالبوم كده
عربي
ان شاء الله في عربي
الاجنبيه اكثر عن العربيه
عليه بس ان دراستي كانت كلها بالانجليزي
واصدقائك كلهم كانوا همم يتكلمون انجليزي
فهايص بخاف اللي انا كبرت فيها بس بالعكس
حابه اني حابه اني ارجع اني اتصل معك همم
مع همم ثقافه العربيه حابه اني اقوي
العربي وارجع اغني بالعربي
بس هاي اللي صار يعني ههه
صح النوم انجليزي بابدا ان شاء الله اسمع
اغاني بالعربي بس اكثر ااا باندا
وبعدين تعرفهم بس كوثر
وايد وايد احب
الاغاني هم هاديه
يعني تحس انها همم شعر يعني مواضيعهم كلها
يعني
عن اشياء خفيفه على القلب
الاغاني اللي اللي تحسسك الحياه حلوه
ايه اكيد
بس مش يعني مش لما اكون بروحي لما اكون مع
جروب اكثر شيء يعني اذا انا اكون صريحه
معك الحين بس اكثر ناس اكثر ناس يحب
اغانيها اصاله
واكيد فهد الكبيسي
ومن بعد
في كم المغني بس اكثر يعني هي تكون اغنيه
جروب يعني
وفي بعد
احب اغاني سعد المجرد
هل هل في اغنيه معينه ممكن تغني عنها
بالعربي
بما ان احنا في الجمهور بتاعنا كله عربي
[موسيقى]
حقيقي
الجام
ع علمي
فضل اجتهادي
نقى في نور الله لك
ما انت
معنى حياتي
انت
اماني والوجود
[موسيقى]
فخري بذاتي
مجد تعلم
[موسيقى]
جميل
[ضحك]
تمام
انا
اتكلم معك اكثر في في الكوره بقى شويه هل
عائشه بتتابع كره القدم هل لها فرق مفضله
في كاس العالم حتى بيعها هل في فرق معينه
شايفه ان هي ممكن تكون هي متوقعه ان هي
تفوز بالبطوله
والله اكيد اكيد
ههه
همم مواليد بلجيكا اشجع بلجيكا
ناخذ كاس العالم
[ضحك]
ان شاء الله قطر ليش لا ان شاء الله قطر
ان شاء الله طيب همم يعني همم
استمتعت الحقيقه
باللايف هذا اللايف همم القصير ال همم
المكثف يعني لكن حابب ان انا همم اسالك في
في النهايه هل في همم رساله حب توصليها ل-
اا الفتيات في قطر والعالم العربي همم هم
بيسعوا ايضا للدخول الى الساحه الغنائيه
وهمم والفنيه بشكل كبير
والله اهم شيء اقدر اقول البنات في العالم
العربي ان اهم شي تقدر تسوي نفسك انها تحب
نفسها اول شيء تسويه تحب نفسها
وتكون واثقه في نفسها وان شاء الله اي شيء
يقدر
يخليك
بالعربي احسن بالانجليزي
شر لكريم ههه
اول كاس عالم
في دوله عربيه
حابه تقولي يعني
احنا وكان تويتر
لنا 12 سنه نشتغل فان شاء الله يعني
يعجبكم الشغل اللي سوينا
ان شاء الله باذن الله انا بشكرك شكرا
جزيلا يا عائشه
وان شاء الله باذن الله ننتظر في الالبوم
الجديد في 2023 ونتمنى ان هو يكون في
اغاني عربيه كثيره عشان خاطر الجمهور هنا
المنتظر لاغاني عربيه وعجبته الاغنيه
العربيه اللي انت قولتيها
[موسيقى]
نشكر ربنا
ان شاء الله باذن الله يوم الخميس
ان شاء الله شكرا